Hello and welcome to my talk.
Dissecting the
quick fix, analyzing
tech-solutionist solutions.
Let me start with a definition.
What is tech solutionism?
Tech solutionism is the
tendency to use technology
to solve a societal, political,
organizational, environmental, ...
... what have you problem.
A few examples should
make this more clear.
Example number one: riots.
What's the problem?
Well... suppressed population
groups, for example,
ethnic minorities are
starting to mobilize.
What do we observe?
This is more likely to
happen when it's hot.
Very hot.
What is the solution?
Well - just install
acclimatization throughout!
And what do we gain?
We don't have to
actually address
those groups' demands.
Example two: mass shootings.
What is the problem?
Since 2014, on
average, there has
been more than one mass
shooting a day in the US.
What do we observe?
You can't always see if
someone's carrying a gun.
What's the solution?
Well - just install advanced
surveillance technology.
And what do we gain?
We don't have to change the
laws related to gun ownership.
Example number three:
climate change.
What is the problem?
Climate change is rendering
parts of the Earth inhabitable
and strongly impacts living
conditions in others.
What's our observation?
Time is passing and we
are less and less on track
to keep the situation
under control.
What's the solution?
Well, we just move to Mars
or somewhere else in space.
What do we gain? ... We
survive and have fun.
If that's the kind
of thing we find fun.
Right?
so yeah, I think by now
it should be pretty clear
what I'm talking about here.
On the other hand,
you'll probably also
have noticed I got more and more
into some kind of cynical tone:
But disgust, sarcasm, cynicism ...
... don't bring us very far.
Why?
Well ... on the one hand, we won't
notice less blatant "solutions",
quote- unquote, when
it's less clear,
like, for example, when talking
about climate change.
What about things
like geoengineering?
That isn't that easy?
And also, we're not never going
to reach those people who don't
already agree with us anyway.
Right ... so I don't think
this is very useful.
On the other hand,
I think what we
should try is to
understand what is
so seductive about this thing.
Well, like the
world already says,
it solves something: good, right?
It solves a problem.
Often it solves a hard
problem, a problem
that otherwise we wouldn't know how
to solve, how to address, even.
It solves a problem we would
have to make sacrifices for.
And we don't want that.
Right ... and often it
just solves a problem
we're terribly scared about.
So what I'm going to try
to do in this talk is
or what I think we need is
some kind of framework
to analyze those proposals,
a framework which does not just
ask technical questions,
because this is something
we are already doing
to some degree.
But I think the technical
aspect is not enough.
And so I'm going
to try to propose
a very simple
framework, a framework
of W questions like what, where,
when, why, who, to whom, how?
(OK that's not a W question - anyway - ... to
help us address things in a systematic way.
And there I'm going to focus
on the more neglected aspects.
So I'm going to focus
on two of these aspects, let
me say what I mean
by the rest of them.
First, what does
the solution do?
And this should include the
complete technical workflow.
Like, from where do
we get the data from?
How do we train our
machine learning models?
How do we evaluate them?
And in this area, we
already have some things
like data set documentation,
model documentation, which
is all great, but which is all
the technical side of things.
Then: where, when, and to whom
were the solution be applied?
This should include the
complete geographic, geographic,
sociopolitical,
et cetera context.
Then: how will this
solution be applied?
And here really
the details matter.
Next, who is implementing
the solution?
That's something I want
to talk about more.
And also, why is the solution
being developed?
There, too, I would like to go
into some detail.
So in other words,
in this talk, I
want to go into the why and
the who, because in my view,
these are the two aspects
which are being neglected most
in this area.
First, let's start with the why.
Why?
So what kind of things
you're going to hear?
Well, we care.
We want to help.
We are here for you.
What kind of things won't
you hear in this area?
And here I'm kind of
splitting it up a bit.
First, what kind of reasons
might individual people
have when they
implement something
or suggest something
which they won't say?
Well, for example, if
I build this thing,
it's going to look good on my resume.
If I build this
thing, it might just
get me a job at company XYZ.
If I build this thing, I might
be able to create a startup.
If I build this thing,
I'm going to learn
that crazy new technology
X ... and ... also it's just so cool
that this can even be done.
Next, in a more indirect way...
When organizations ...
When organizations do
something, propose something,
what are the things
they don't say?
Well, if we build
this, we are going
to strengthen our
existing market monopoly.
If we build this,
we're going to distract
from that bad thing that
recently ran through the news.
If we build this, we're
going to be the good guys.
And now in a more indirect way,
let's think about side effects.
If we build this,
we are going to be
able to extract valuable data
for our targeted advertising.
If we build this, we are
going to get data to feed back
into our neural networks.
If we build this, we're going
to have the foot in the door.
If we build this ...
Public institutions
will be stuck with us.
Now let's step up one level and
think ... this is about technology.
And technology is
something that shapes us,
that forms us in our daily lives.
If we build this, we
define how people live.
define how people think.
If we build this, we
define what people feel.
define who people are.
By now...
I think it should
be clear what I mean
by motivations for this thing...
... why things are
built. Now let's
switch to the next thing, the
who, who builds something.
And here I want to be a bit
more clear from the outset who
I'm talking about, because this
can be a bit ambiguous, who
could also mean like, to whom
the solution is being applied.
I'm not talking about
that aspect right now.
What I mean is ... let me spell it out.
Who designs, implements
and hosts the solution?
Who processes its data?
Who knows how it works
and can fix problems?
So let's take an example.
And as an example,
I'm going to talk
about education technology,
also abbreviated as edtech,
which has been booming.
A lot over the last
years, especially,
of course, due to the pandemic.
OK ... for edtech.
What kind of things
are you going to hear?
Well, with adaptive
technology xyz,
individual learners'
needs are being met.
With adaptive
technology xyz
teachers can focus on doing what
they do best. With technology
xyz
We make learning more
effective and efficient.
What kind of things
won't you hear?
How it works.
With technology xyz we are going
to extract, store,
and process lots of very
private and personal data.
With technology xyz
We are constantly
monitoring your behavior.
With technology xyz
YOU learn.
WE'RE learning from YOU.
Now this is about
education technology ...
what is education ... education is
like forming people, or shaping
young people.
Yeah forming people,
let's just say like this.
So what this really
means, like, is
we define how people learn,
how we define what is learned.
We define what
deserves to be learned.
We define what deserves
to be forgotten.
And stepping up a level,
somehow a bit more abstract.
What is learned?
Common knowledge is
building a culture.
This is like, who we are.
So what does this mean?
We define the past.
We define the present.
We define the future.
We define what it
means to be human.
OK now, you may be
wondering, can you say again
how this is about the who?
Yeah, and so, before I was
saying what I mean by "who is".
Who designs, implements
and hosts the solution.
Who processes and
stores the data.
And who knows how it works.
This who ...
Or let's say, like, "these whos",
we can put them on a dimension.
And here I want to
ask you to go with me
and imagine a dimension,
a continuous dimension
where on the one hand,
we have the public
and on the other hand,
we have the private.
On the one hand, for
the public institution,
I'm asking you to imagine
an ideal democracy.
We all know there is
no ideal democracy,
but we can all strive for one,
at least hope for one, perhaps.
So on the one hand, this idea of
democracy, on the other hand,
for the private
institutions, this
can be anything, can
be a corporation,
a foundation, an
NGO ... doesn't really
matter the official status.
What are defining
features of this?
Who's on that dimension?
For the ideal democracy
you have a democratic decision
process with participation
ranging on top.
Well, the private
end of the dimension,
we can only say what's lacking,
like this democratic process
... otherwise could be anything.
What are defining values
for the public institution?
These are things like fairness,
justice, human rights,
accountability ... For the
private institution,
again, it will depend on
that institution's agenda.
So now if I assume this
dimension of "whos" ...
What kind of difference
would that make?
For one.
Public institutions don't have
to gather data to make money.
to keep their trade secrets.
Public institutions don't need
to worry about market position.
Next, what difference
does this make
in political and legal respects?
Public institutions can be
held to ensure transparency.
Public institutions can be held
accountable.
Public institutions can
be obliged to be fair.
And again stepping a bit
up a bit, in abstraction ...
What difference does it make
to human rights and values?
Public institutions can be
held to prioritize values
over feasibility.
Public institutions
can be obliged
to respect human rights.
Public institutions can
be held to promote, not
erase, individuality.
Now, you may be wondering...
Still ... I'm not a CEO...
What can I do?
Well, I don't really know.
But I think one thing is,
perhaps we can make choices.
This will depend.
Perhaps we can make
choices like who
we work for, what we
vote for, whether we
organize politically.
Or one step back, perhaps even
we can question the things
we are being told ... pretty much
in the spirit of this talk,
asking questions.
Or even perhaps
we can start
with a bit of imagination.
Maybe data science
could be different.
What if?
Data were used not to perpetuate,
but to change the status quo.
What if they were used to
make social relations more
egalitarian, more just?
What if data were used to
subvert privileges, not
reinforce them?
Thank you very much
for your attention.